is rudy guiliani secretly working for
robert muller i'm not actually
suggesting that he is in in a serious
manner but since Rudy Guiliani has
joined Donald Trump's legal team it has
been just like one faceplant after
another that are really not making
Donald Trump look good not that he
looked great before Rudy joined his team
first Giuliani joined Trump's legal team
and immediately did an interview where
he admitted that actually yeah Trump did
repay Michael Cohen a hundred and thirty
thousand dollars in stormy Daniels hush
money after countless denials from Trump
in the White House and everybody else
then Rudy Giuliani in another interview
that was just very strange tried to walk
back his own claim by saying things he
says are just rumors basically writing
off his own assertions as just rumors
that he had heard then Rudy Giuliani
comes out and makes the very strange
statement after the conviction of
Michael Cohen's business partner of Gani
Friedman that he meaning Giuliani
himself has as much to do with New York
City taxis as Michael Cohen had to do
with New York City taxes which is insane
since Michael Cohen actually had a lot
to do with New York City taxes and then
last week I told you about this
absolutely outrageous interview that
Rudy Giuliani did where he said that
Donald Trump was at risk of committing
perjury if interviewed by Robert Moeller
not because Trump would be lying but
because the truth is relative and almost
like postmodernist critique of the
Moller investigation not exactly what I
would expect from a lawyer for Donald
Trump and now the latest and I'm gonna
play some clips for you today is that
Rudy Giuliani appeared on CNN and just
made no sense and I'm not saying he made
no sense in some symbolic way he
literally made no sense like I didn't
know what he was talking about during
this interview here he is asked by Dan
abash about whether this whole Spygate
thing which we haven't even talked about
because it's so crazy whether the entire
Spygate thing is an attempt to just
interfere with robert Moeller's
investigation I cannot understand Rudy
Giuliani's answer take a listen let's
start right there the the f
by confidential source is directly
connected to this ongoing investigation
into the president's campaign doesn't it
create an appearance that the White
House is interfering with this
investigation
I don't see that Dana I think that the
White House has every right to know the
president has every right to know as
commander-in-chief
after all the investigation as the
Democrat said reveal nothing new so
there's nothing to us that means
exculpatory because the new would be if
something turned up that was a that was
a surprise so it should be very easy to
brief us and we can come out of it
saying same thing nothing new or Moo
might come out and be able to say
nothing in which case you'll have a real
signal what is he talking about look I
don't understand what he's talking about
it he seems confused and sort of slow
and this went on for 20 minutes here's
another section where Rudy Giuliani's
answer is so in can hear an incoherent
that Dan abash changes topic altogether
to is Trump gonna sit down with Robert
Muller because she doesn't know what
he's talking about and if you're
watching you'll notice that when she
asks will Trump sit down with Muller
Rudy Giuliani's eyes bug out as she
asked the question and then of course
totally incoherent answer but if it is
true and it's dangerous to this man he
better be protected already I don't
believe he's being protected says to me
that maybe the FBI and the Justice
Department is being a little
hypocritical here why is that well they
said he can't be revealed because it's
dangerous now he's been revealed Wall
Street Journal several other newspapers
if that man is the man he better be
protected I'm not sure but I hear he's
not know what's going on mr. mayor I
want to just ask point blank will the
president
sit down with Robert Muller even if the
White House legal team or you anybody on
his legal legal team doesn't get a
briefing about this confidential source
well if he wasn't thinking about it and
it wasn't an active possibility we'd be
finished with that by now we've moved on
then they get to hey Rudy you keep
talking about the entire investigate
being rigged how is any of this rigged
and here is Rudy Giuliani's answer it's
rigged I just want to go through because
I know you use this this term a lot and
obviously so does the president this
investigation has already brought
charges against 22 people and entities
including 13 Russians who have been
indicted for trying to change the the
outcome of the election so how is it a
rigged investigation when they already
when they're not even close to being
done and they already have this in their
pocket well because first of all the two
different investigations right the
counterintelligence investigation is now
over for over a year and they weren't
disclosing it to anybody
immediately that raises questions in my
mind why not I think why not because it
clears the present then you get the
Comey thing which is a leak of a
confidential memo which is illegal for
an FBI official to do it and that
becomes the basis for appointing Muller
I'm not saying well the problem is the
leak the problem is the leak it's kind
of sad isn't it Pat like what the hell
is Rudy Giuliani talking about here and
he was a very good prosecutor he was
involved in some interesting mob cases
related to Donnie Brasco he had a lot of
policies as New York City mayor that I
disagreed with but he was sort of a
normal mayor he did some measurably good
things in New York City what is the guy
talking about here he also in the center
of you admitted that the Spygate thing
was just a PR ploy right I think you
know to quote Donald Trump from a couple
weeks ago he just joined Trump's legal
team he needs to go back and read over
his notes and think about you know what
the story is right yeah you inform
himself before he can be doing
interviews and yeah Pat's pointing out
what the entire point of all of this
Spygate stuff is which is just try to
discredit Mulder by pushing Spygate the
idea that there's like some kind of
organized there was an organized spy in
the Trump campaign being handled by the
FBI or something along those lines
Giuliani has been a disaster for Trump
since he was hired and these are the
behaviors of someone who knows that
their client is in trouble right it's
all a discredited witch-hunt
Moeller can't be trusted Trump can't
talk to Mulder because the truth is
relative there could be a perjury trap
and Spygate makes the entire thing
irrelevant as opposed to let's
all get together as adults and clear
this up so that the president can get
back to focusing on just being the
president and unfortunately the problem
is that as disastrous as Rudy Giuliani
has been when it comes to the truth
Trump won the election by lying and
there's a lot that lying can achieve for
a candidate like Trump with a cult of
personality around him the way he has so
Rudy Giuliani can probably do a lot of
good by going out and lying as well
hopefully Muller is not going to be
distracted by it but the PR war can be
very positively impacted by having
somebody like Rudy go out and just tell
lies send me your thoughts if you
understood this interview I'm on Twitter
at D Pakman and the show is on twitter
at david pakman show the video you just
watched was made possible by support
from you please go to patreon.com slash
david pakman show you can make a pledge
of as little as $1 per month and every
dollar helps to support the work that
we're doing particularly in light of the
YouTube ad boycott which has been really
bad